this right here is an equation for a
parabola and the goal of this video is
to find an alternate order to explore an
alternate method for finding the focus
and directrix of this parabola from the
equation so the first thing I like to do
is solve explicitly for y I don't know
my brain just processes things better
that way so let's get this 20 3 or 4 to
the right hand side so let's add 23 over
4 to both sides and then we'll get Y is
equal to negative 1/3 times X minus 1
squared plus 23 over 4 now let's remind
ourselves what we've learned about folk
folk I and and directrix is I think is
how to say it so the focus if the focus
of a parabola is at the point a comma B
and the directrix the directrix
directrix is the line y equals K we've
shown in other videos with a little bit
of hairy algebra that the equation of
the parabola in the form like this is
going to be Y is equal to 1 over 2 times
B minus K and this B minus K is then the
difference between this y-coordinate and
this Y value I guess you could say times
X minus 1 squared plus B plus K I'm
sorry not X minus 1 I'm going to confuse
with this X minus a squared X minus a
squared plus B plus K over over 2 the
focus is a comma B then the direction is
y equals K and this is going to be the
equation of the parabola well we've
already seen a technique where look we
can see the different parts we can see
that ok this X minus 1 squared actually
let me do this in a different color
this X minus 1 squared corresponds to
the X minus a squared and so one
corresponds to a so just like that we
know that a is going to be equal to 1
and actually let me just write that down
a
is equal to 1 in this example right over
here and then you could see you could
see that the negative 1/3 over here
corresponds to the 1 over 2 B minus K
and you would see that the 23 over 4
corresponds to the B plus K over 2 now
the the first technique that we explored
we said okay let's set negative 1/3 to
this thing right over here solve for B
minus K we're not solving for B or K
we're solving for the expression B minus
K so you get B minus K equals something
and then you could use 23 over four and
this to solve for B plus K so you get B
plus K equals something and then you
have two equations two unknowns you can
solve for B and K what I want to do in
this video is explore a different method
that really uses our knowledge of the
vertex of a parabola to be able to
figure out where the focus and the
directrix is going to be so let's think
about the vertex of this parabola right
over here remember the vertex if the
parabola is upward opening like this the
vertex is this is this minimum point if
it is downward opening it's going to be
this maximum point and so when you look
over here you see that you have a
negative 1/3 in front of the X minus 1
squared so this quantity over here is
either going to be 0 or negative so it's
always going it's not going to add to
23:04 it's either going to add nothing
or take away from it so this thing is
going to hit a maximum point when this
thing is 0 when this thing is 0 and
other and it's just going to go down
from there and when this thing is 0 Y is
going to be equal to 23 over 4 so our
vertex is going to be that maximum point
our vertex is going to be well when does
this equal 0 well when x equals 1 when x
equals 1 you get 1 minus 1 squared so 0
squared times negative 1/3 this is 0 so
when X is equal to 1 we're at our
maximum Y value of 23 over 4 which is 5
and 3/4 it's actually let me let me
write that as a knock I'll leave it just
like that's our vertex 23 or 4 and it is
a downward-opening it is a
downward-opening parabola so actually
let me start to draw this so let me get
some axes here so we have to go all the
way up to 5 and 3/4 so let's make this
our that's our Y this is our y-axis this
is the x-axis let's the x-axis and see
we're going to see we go to one let's
call that one let's call that two and
then I want to get let's see if I go to
5 and 3/4 let's go up to see 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 we can able them 1 2 3 4 5 6 and 7 and
so our vertex our vertex is right over
here 1 comma 23 over 4 so it's 5 and 3/4
so it's going to be right around right
around there and as we said since we
have a negative value in front of this X
minus 1 squared term I guess we could
call it this is going to be a
downward-opening parabola this is going
to be a maximum point so our actual
parabola is going to look it's going to
look something it's going to look
something like this it's going to look
something something like this and we
could we could obviously I'm hand
drawing it so it's not not going to be
exactly perfect but hopefully you get
you get the general idea of what the
parabola is going to what the parabola
is going to look like I'm actually let
me let me just do part of it I actually
don't know that much information about
the parabola just yet I'm just going to
draw it like that so we don't know just
yet where the where the directrix and
focus is but we do know a few things the
focus is going to sit on the same I
guess you could say the same x-value as
the vertex so if we draw this is x
equals 1 if x equals 1 we know from our
experience with focuses foci Kitt's and
that they want to sit on the same axis
as as the vertex so the focus
might be right over here and then the
directrix is going to be an equal
distant on the other side equidistant on
the other side so the directrix might be
something like this might be right over
here and once again I haven't figured it
out yet but what we know is that because
this point the vertex sits on the
parabola by definition has to be
equidistant from the focus and from the
focus and the directrix so this distance
has to be the same as this distance
right over here and what's another way
of thinking about this entire distance
remember this coordinate right over here
is a comma B and this is the line y is
equal to K this is y equals K so what's
what's this distance in yellow
what's this difference in Y going to be
well you could call that in this case
the directrix is above the focus so you
could say that this would be K minus B
or you could say it's the absolute value
of B minus K this would actually always
work it'll always give you kind of the
positive distance so if we knew what
what the absolute value of B minus K is
if we knew this distance then we just
put it in half the directrix is going to
be that distance half the distance above
and then the focus is going to be half
the distance below so let's see if we
can figure this out and we can figure
this out because we see in this I guess
you could say this equation you can see
where they where B minus K is involved 1
over 2 times B minus K needs to be equal
to negative 1/3 so let's solve for B
minus K so we get we get 1 over 2 times
B minus K is going to be equal to
negative 1/3 once again this corresponds
to that it's going to be equal to
negative 1/3 we could take the
reciprocal of both sides we get 2 times
B minus K is equal to is equal to 3 is
equal to 3 now we can divide both sides
we can divide both sides by
- and so we're going to get we're going
to get B B minus K is equal to is equal
to was that three-halves three-halves B
minus K is equal to let me make sure I
happen to be a negative 3 so this has to
be negative three-halves and so if you
took the absolute value of B minus K
you're going to get you're going to get
positive three-halves or if you took K
minus B you're going to get positive
three-halves so just like that using
this part look just just actually
matching the negative one-third to this
part of this equation we're able to
solve for the absolute value of B minus
K which is going to be the distance
between the y axis in the y direction
between the focus and the directrix so
this distance right over here is
three-halves so what is half that
distance so the reason why i care about
half that distance is because then i can
calculate where the focus is because is
going to be half that distance below the
vertex and I can say well that and
whatever that distance is it's going to
be that distance also above the
directrix
so half that distance so 1/2 times
three-halves is equal to three-fourths
so just like that we're able to figure
out the directrix it's going to be 3/4
above this so I could say the directrix
so let me see I'm running out of space
the directrix is going to be y is equal
to the y coordinate of the focus so 23
I'm sorry the y coordinate of the vertex
would be careful my little language it's
going to be equal to the y-coordinate of
the vertex plus plus 3/4 plus 3/4 so
plus 3/4 which is equal to 26 over 4
which is equal to what is that that's
equal to 6 and 1/2 so this right over
here actually I got pretty close when
true it is actually going to be the
directrix Y is equal to 6 and 1/2 and
the focus well we know the x coordinate
of the focus a is going to be equal to 1
and B is going to be 3/4 less than the y
coordinate of the directrix
so 23 over 4
- 3/4 it's going to be twenty three over
four twenty three over four - three
fourths which is 20 over 4 which is just
equal to it is just equal to five and we
are done that's the focus one comma five
directrix is y is equal to six and a
half